[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
LISE A. JOHNSON: So
thanks for having us back.
It's nice to get re-invited.
It means we didn't do so
poorly the first time around.
So my name is Lise Johnson,
and I am most recently
of Rocky Vista University, which
is a very small medical school
in Colorado.
But I, until recently, worked
at University of Washington,
so I'm very happy to
be back in the region
enjoying some rain again.
So today, we're going to
be talking about our book.
And the first thing
we want to talk about
is, why would we write
a book about worries?
So this is a picture of my
daughter a couple of years ago.
She's much more
advanced these days.
But I think, for
me, I've always been
kind of a worrier, a worrywart,
any way you want to phrase it.
I've always been stressed
out about things.
But this really accelerated as a
problem for me when I had kids.
I don't know if anybody else
has had this experience,
but I realized when I had
kids that there was, like,
new categories of things
that I had never even thought
about that I needed to
worry about all of a sudden.
And as I would Google them,
I would get a little stressed
out, because you get
1,000 hits for anything
that you could potentially
be worried about.
And it started to really become
kind of a problem in my life,
that I was worrying about
all of these things.
And my husband
said to me one day,
as I was freaking out
about something trivial
in retrospect, that,
as a scientist,
you could probably figure out
what you need to worry about
and what you don't.
And I had this realization
that that was actually true.
And so I started to kind of
investigate in a logical way
the things that I thought
were important to worry about
and the things
that I didn't think
were important to worry about.
And as I was in this process,
I realized lots of other people
are stressed out about
lots of things, as well.
And that kind of kicked
off this process.
And then I worked with
Eric Chudler at the time,
and he graciously agreed to
work on the project with me.
And that's kind of
how we got started.
Well, one of the things
that I've noticed
is that this is an
extremely timely topic.
Every time I tell
someone, hey, I'm
writing this book about worries,
they always respond with,
did you write a chapter
on, fill in the blank.
Everybody has something that
they're really worried about.
So we're going to talk
about some of the things
that we discuss in the
book, and then we're
going to give some tips on how
people can investigate worries
on their own.
But first we want to talk
about what our methods were.
So Eric and I are
both scientists,
and I would venture to say, kind
of nerdy scientists at that.
And so we felt that
we needed to have
a process and some
defining principles
as we embarked on this project.
So we thought about,
well, what sorts of things
should you reasonably
be worried about?
And we said there are
really three things that
are important to consider.
The first is how likely is
something to happen to you.
The second is, how
bad is it going
to be if it does in
fact happen to you.
And then finally, what
can you do to prevent it
from happening to you.
And we decided, really,
that if something
is likely to happen to you,
if it's going to be bad,
and if you can do
something about it, then
that sort of forms this
magic space of things
that you should worry about.
Everything else,
if it's unlikely,
you don't need to
worry about it.
If it's not really
going to be a big deal,
you don't need to
worry about it.
And if there's nothing
you can do about it,
even if it is really
going to be a problem,
then you don't really need
to worry about that either,
because there's nothing you
can really do to prevent it.
So it's kind of a
waste of your time.
So we quantified our
worries in this way.
So for each of our problems
that we investigated,
each of our topics
we created what we
call the Worry Index.
So the Worry Index is really
a very loose quantification.
It's really based on,
we investigated this,
we talked about it, and we
scaled each of these worries
with respect to each other.
So it's not something to really
take religiously to the bank.
It's a good place to
start, and so we're
going to talk about how we feel
about each of these topics.
And hopefully, we'll have
a chance for you guys
to participate, as well.
ERIC CHUDLER: So as
an example, we're
going to talk about
asteroid strikes.
So that's one of the things
that some people worry about.
In fact millions years
ago, the dinosaurs
were maybe worrying about
getting struck by an asteroid
if they had a large enough
brain to worry about things.
But some people do worry
about, maybe all life on Earth
will be destroyed again.
And so I'm going to give this
as an example about the criteria
that we used, and then we're
going to give you some examples
to do on your own.
So for an asteroid
strike, the likelihood
of getting struck by a
large asteroid is minuscule.
So there are a couple
of sentry systems
here in the United States,
and also in Europe,
that are scanning the skies
for large objects on their way
to Earth.
And it's estimated that
the next significant one
within the next 100 years has
almost a 99.9% chance that it
will miss Earth.
So the likelihood of a large
asteroid hitting the earth
is almost nil.
So because it's unlikely,
nothing to worry about.
So you should be happy
about that-- very unlikely.
Can you do anything
to prevent it?
So if there is an
asteroid coming to Earth,
is there some way that you
can avert this disaster?
So how many of you
have seen "Armageddon,"
with Ben Affleck
and Bruce Willis?
Yeah, most of you
have seen that one.
All right, would that work?
No, it's not going to work.
If you put a nuclear
bomb on an asteroid,
instead of one asteroid
coming down to Earth,
you're going to get maybe
101, and it will still
be a big problem.
We do not have any
technology at this time
to prevent an asteroid if
it was coming toward us.
Some technologies that
are being thought of,
well, maybe if you
can break it up
into tiny, tiny little
pieces, maybe that would work.
Because our atmosphere is being
bombarded by asteroids all
the time, but
they're small enough
they burn up in the atmosphere.
It doesn't cause a problem.
Other technologies might
be to send something up,
and rather than
break it apart, just
nudge it a little
bit off course.
Because if you catch it soon
enough, because the Earth is
moving, all you have to do
is change the trajectory
a little bit, and the Earth
will move out of the way
so the asteroid won't hit.
Another technology would
be to put up a large object
and gravitationally
pull the asteroid away,
again, to divert it off course.
And that would also
cause it to miss.
Can we do that now?
No.
So we can't do
anything to prevent
it-- so nothing to worry about.
Now, if it did happen,
though, if it does happen,
just like it happened
millions of years ago,
it would wipe out a
lot of life on Earth,
including all human life.
So the consequence
is devastating,
if something like that happened.
All human life would probably
be destroyed, unfortunately.
So when you add all
these up together,
this is where we would place
it, on that lower left side.
It's unlikely to happen.
There's nothing
you can do about,
although the consequence
would be bad.
But because of
those two criteria,
getting struck by an asteroid is
nothing for you to worry about.
So those are the
methods we used.
We looked at the data of the
likelihood, the consequence,
and can you do
anything to prevent it.
So now it's audience
participation time.
So all of you should
have a piece of paper
with a little graph
on it, a little plot.
And your job is to
assign a little dot,
and the size of the dot is
going to be the consequence.
And you should be plotting
it on the two scales.
So Lise's going to
introduce the first one.
LISE A. JOHNSON: OK,
so the first thing
we're going to talk
about is mercury.
So everybody play along.
It's after lunch, so
everybody wake up.
Participation is key.
I want you, on your
plot, to make a bubble
relative to the size that you
think it should be, and then
also to--
oh, yeah, exactly.
Eric put up this nice plot.
So put it in the quadrant
that you think it belongs in,
and then give it a size relative
to the magnitude of the problem
that you think it is.
I'll give you just
a minute to do that,
and then we'll continue.
Everybody has to play.
Commit.
OK, so raise your
hand if you think
that it belongs in this
quadrant down here-- unlikely,
and you can't do
anything to stop it.
Excellent.
How about, unlikely and you
can do something about it?
Yes, excellent.
Some people think so.
Likely to happen, but you
can't do anything about it.
This is sort of the
fatalistic category down here.
A few.
And how about up here?
Likely to happen, and you
can do something about it,
therefore you should worry.
OK, some of you aren't
playing, but that's fine.
You'll get into it.
So here's where we put it.
So we actually put it up
here in the Worry category,
and it gets a
relatively large dot.
So why is that?
I kind of primed you in thinking
about this by giving you
a picture of a
fish, so many people
are thinking about
methyl mercury, which
is part of our diet, and we
worry about it in that sense.
And that is a problem.
But there's also
another form of mercury
that you might
encounter, and that
would be elemental mercury.
So how many people have actually
seen mercury in real life?
Yeah, so it's very cool, right?
My mom tells me stories about
when she was a kid, in science
class, they would actually
give her a blob of mercury
to roll around in her hand.
And it was so exciting because
it's silvery and it's neat.
Everybody thinks
it's neat, and people
have thought that it's neat for
thousands of years, actually.
So historically, it's been
used for medicinal purposes.
It used to be a very common
treatment for syphilis,
for example.
It's been used for sort
of magical or ritualistic
purposes, and it still is.
It's used in mining,
because it forms amalgams
with both gold and silver.
And it's used in fillings.
Does anybody have
silver fillings.
You probably-- or
gold fillings also.
You also have some
mercury in there,
because it forms an amalgam.
So the problem
with mercury that,
in addition to being very cool,
it's obviously also very toxic.
And mercury is most toxic, not
when you put it on your skin
or even when you eat it,
but when you inhale it.
So elemental mercury is most
dangerous when you inhale it.
Which is strange, because
you don't think about a metal
as being particularly vaporous.
But mercury is a strange metal.
And so it's most easily
absorbed into your body
if you inhale it.
And then it crosses
into your blood,
and then it crosses
into your brain.
And there are a number
of negative side
effects associated with that.
So elemental mercury is
very much to be avoided.
And we don't usually encounter
it in commercial products
anymore.
It used to be in
thermometers, but they've
been highly phased out.
And you used to find it in
science classes and fishing
lures and all kinds of places.
The problem is that, even
though we don't manufacture
those products anymore, even
though we don't distribute it
to science classes
for kids to play
with in the palm of
their hand, it still
exists in a legacy form.
And once it is distributed
in the environment--
once you break a thermometer,
once you spill mercury--
it's very, very difficult
and expensive to clean it up.
You can't sweep it up.
You can't vacuum it up.
You can't just dump it down
the drain, because it persists.
And there have been examples
of children finding it
in their science classrooms
and taking it home and playing
with it.
And they have to
take their houses
literally down to
the studs in order
to decontaminate the house.
There has been an
example of somebody
who broke a mercury thermometer
20 years prior in their home,
and they were still recording
measurable levels of mercury
vapor in the bathroom.
So that can obviously
be very problematic.
Methyl mercury, which we're
familiar with in terms of fish,
is also a problem.
But it's hard to say how
big of a problem it is.
And there's lots of confounders.
So clearly having too much
methyl mercury is toxic.
And we know that because
of an unfortunate incident
in Minamata, Japan a
number of years ago.
But it's sort of the
in-between levels
are harder to
quantify, because there
are so many individual
differences,
and because consuming fish,
which is sort of the largest
source of methyl mercury,
is also really good
for you in lots of other ways.
So it's this strange
balance between,
fish is really good for you
and your cognitive development,
but mercury is
really bad for you
and your cognitive development.
So how do we find
the happy medium
between those two things?
And I think it's fair to say
that scientists are still
arguing about that.
But one thing we can
say is that, fish
that are higher up on the food
chain, which usually means
the big ones that
eat the littler ones,
are going to have more
concentration of methyl
mercury than ones that are
lower on the food chain.
Which means if you
eat sardines, you're
going to get less mercury
than if you're eating shark
or swordfish, for example.
So most experts recommend now
that you should try and eat
fish, but you
should eat fish that
are lower on the food
chain and fish that are
higher in omega fatty acids.
ERIC CHUDLER: So this
one gets a frowny face.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Question--
how do you think
about the scale on the x-axis?
Is this a percentage
chance of encountering it
in your lifetime?
ERIC CHUDLER:
Repeat the question.
LISE A. JOHNSON: Oh, to
repeat the question, sorry.
So how do we scale
it on the x-axis?
Is it sort of a lifetime risk?
I tend to think of it as more
of like a snapshot in time.
So at this point
in time, if you,
assuming that you have
any exposure at all--
like you are eating fish, or
you are living in a world where
there is elemental mercury--
what is your likelihood?
So it's a little
bit personalized.
Not everybody's going to have
the same level of exposure,
which is one of the reasons why
we ask people not to read too
much into our Worry
Index, but really
to think about how this
might apply to you.
ERIC CHUDLER: All
right, your next worry
is, in honor of Brain Awareness
Week, which is actually
an international event
going on next week,
is your brain-eating amoeba.
And this was actually something
that was in the newspaper
just very recently.
There was a case in Washington.
And so you may have seen the
headlines in "The Seattle
Times" and on the news.
So again on your
sheets of paper,
where would this worry be.
Pick which quadrant
it should be.
And again, just to
help you out, it
looks like most
people are finished.
So raise your hand if this
is a concern of yours,
that it's unlikely to
happen, and there's
nothing you can do to stop it.
Unlikely to happen, but there's
How about above that--
it's unlikely to happen,
but there is something
you can do about it.
Maybe a few more people.
How about, it's
likely to happen,
and you can't do
anything about it.
So likely to happen, at
the bottom right-hand side.
And how about just
above that-- this
is something that you
should worry about.
This is where we placed it.
It's something that is
very unlikely to happen.
There is something that
you can do about it.
But it has a large circle,
because if it happens to you,
it's 97% fatal.
OK, so what is a
brain-eating amoeba?
It's a small single-celled
organism that
is found in warm, fresh water.
If it's inhaled
through your nose--
not in many cases,
in a few cases
it gets into the upper
part of your nose,
where it then crawls--
I guess, if an amoeba crawls--
through the sinuses
up to your brain
where it starts
eating brain tissue.
And that's bad, as
you might imagine.
But it's very
unlikely to happen.
Many waters are contaminated
with this amoeba,
but very few people
come down with it.
In fact, for the last
about 30 years or so,
there's only been
about 150 cases or so.
So it's very unlikely to happen,
even though a lot of water
is contaminated.
You could also not
contract the disease
by swallowing the water.
It must go into
your nasal passages.
So just because you
swallow the water,
the amoeba's killed in
your digestive system.
The other way you can get it, if
you're not in this fresh water,
in like a spa or
something like that,
there's a device
called a neti pot.
So some people use a neti pot
to clean out their sinuses.
You're supposed to use
purified or sterilized water.
And then you tip the
pot into your nose
to clean your sinuses.
Well, if that water
is contaminated,
then the amoeba can
get up in your nose,
and it can then crawl
into your brain,
and I'm sorry to say, kill you.
So again, not something
to worry about,
but the headlines make
it as if it is something
that you should worry about.
"The Seattle Times" had a big
headline, brain-eating amoeba,
doctor says it
can happen to you.
But very, very unlikely,
even though it's
a somewhat common bacteria.
So nothing to worry about.
The next one--
LISE A. JOHNSON: OK, so flame
retardants-- first of all,
does everybody know
what I mean when
I talk about flame retardants?
These are chemicals that
are added a lot of times
to furniture, most
commonly furniture,
also baby toys and bouncers
and stuff, and carpets and car
seats, in order,
obviously, to stop them
from catching on fire.
So now that you
know what they are,
write down quickly
what you think.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does asbestos count?
LISE A. JOHNSON: No.
ERIC CHUDLER: That's
a separate chapter.
LISE A. JOHNSON:
Different chapter, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are we
talking about the risk
of being injured by
flame retardants,
or injured by the lack
of flame retardants?
LISE A. JOHNSON: Of being
injured by flame retardants.
Just to remind you,
here's our plot,
to put it in one
of these quadrants.
Although that's an
interesting question,
about whether it's being
injured by or the lack of.
Both, obviously,
could be a problem.
But in this case, we're
talking about the chemicals.
OK, so who thinks we belong
down here, not really a problem.
OK.
How about up here?
A few as well.
So that would be
in the unlikely,
and you can do
something about it.
So it's highly preventable,
but not highly likely.
How about, it's
likely to happen,
but you can't really
do anything about it,
so don't worry about it.
And how many think it's
something to worry about?
OK.
So I'll tell you that
this is the topic that
sent me kind of over the edge.
I was worried about flame
retardants in our sofa,
and I actually made my
husband take our sofa out
to the garage, and we
lived without a sofa
for several months.
And I'll tell you why.
So before I do, let me show
you where we assigned it
and explain a little
bit about this plot.
OK, so first of all,
this circle right here,
it looks like it's
slightly off to the left,
but it's meant to be centered
right on the 50% line.
And it's about 50% size.
And that means, actually,
when I give something
a score of 50-50, it
means I have no idea.
OK, so this is what
I like to call,
in the zone of uncertainty.
And the reason for
that is because, when
we're talking about flame
retardant chemicals,
there are thousands
of different chemicals
that are out there in the
wild that are being used.
And most of them
have actually not
been rigorously studied for
their effects on human health.
So a little bit of history
on flame retardants--
they were originally
added to furniture by law
in the state of
California around--
oh, I'm going to
get my date wrong--
I think it was 1975.
Because there was a problem
with people smoking.
And when they fall asleep with
a cigarette in their mouth
or close by, they would light
their furniture on fire.
And in order to get
around this problem,
the state of California
mandated that furniture
meet a certain
flame-resistant standard.
And the way that manufacturers
achieved the standard
was by adding flame
retardant chemicals.
And because California
is such a huge market,
most manufacturers
didn't make furniture
for the rest of the world
and furniture for California.
They just added flame retardant
chemicals to everything.
So the problem is that
many of these chemicals
are associated with all
kinds of health problems-- so
endocrine problems, and
developmental problems, growth
problems.
Cancer, obviously, is
always on the list.
But they haven't really been--
the whole sum of them haven't
been rigorously tested.
And so we still don't really
know how big of a problem
they are.
We know that they are persistent
environmental pollutants.
So you can isolate them in
the fat of arctic polar bears,
which turns out to
be the gold standard
for a persistent
environmental pollutant.
If you can find it in a polar
bear, then we have a problem.
And they're basically
everywhere in the environment,
which is why we get a pretty
low preventability score.
They're in your car.
They're in your house.
Any place that has
foam, in particular,
is often treated with
flame retardant chemicals.
So recently, about 2013,
the state of California
reversed its technical bulletin.
It's called technical
bulletin 117,
and now there's an
amendment in 2013
saying you don't have to
have the same sort of flame
retardant properties
in your furniture.
And so now it is legal to
make furniture that doesn't
have added flame retardants.
And some manufacturers do.
So you can find a sofa--
Ikea makes them, which is where
we got non-flame retardant
sofa is from Ikea.
And you can buy baby
products that also don't have
flame retardants added to them.
It's probably worth
doing, in my opinion,
just because of the
level of uncertainty.
But I can't say
for sure that this
is going to hurt
you or not hurt you,
because the data is
really not in on that.
Does that sort of
make sense, as to why
it ends up in this particular
zone of uncertainty?
The other thing that sort
of surrounds this issue,
and it gets back to his
question over here about
whether we should be
concerned about not having
flame retardants-- so is there
a problem with your furniture
catching on fire?
And the answer is probably yes.
Like we build our furniture
and many of the things
that are in our house out of
incredibly flammable materials.
And foam, in particular,
goes up really fast.
It burns really
hot, and it produces
lots of really toxic smoke.
So that's obviously not ideal.
It turns out that in tests done
by the Consumer Product Safety
Division, sofas that were
treated with flame retardants
didn't actually burn any
less quickly, any less hot,
and they were a little bit
more toxic because of the added
flame retardants.
So it's not that we don't have
a problem with our furniture
catching on fire.
It's less of a problem
now, because fewer people
smoke in bed or in their
couches or whatever.
But we do have incredibly
flammable furniture.
It's just that the flame
retardants don't really
help with that problem.
So good news and bad news there.
So now, as I promised you, we're
going to talk about some tips
for doing it yourself.
So the first thing
I'll say is that, when
we started on this
project, at least
I thought that it was going
to be much easier to do
than it turned out to be.
Because I thought,
I have a huge PhD,
and I know how to read a paper.
I'll just go to the literature,
and I will read papers,
and I will decide.
And it turned out to
be really hard to do,
partly because it's
really hard to identify
good sources in a field
that is not your own field.
So we had to spend some time
thinking about how we really
were going to identify good
sources and credible sources,
and sort of condense
the information.
So we came up with a tip sheet,
which we've actually included
in the appendix of the book.
And I'm going to give
it to you for free right
here, all my secrets, right now.
So the first thing
that I would suggest
is first to identify your
priorities, the things that you
would like to worry about.
And that's because we've
created this Worry Index,
but it's based on what we
think is worth worrying about,
not necessarily what
everybody else thinks
is worth worrying about.
And everybody is different.
Everybody's
individual, so you have
to make your own
sort of priorities
before you even start.
Because otherwise,
you can dig yourself
into a very deep
hole very quickly.
The second point is to
use credible sources.
And this is the
part where I really
see people going wrong quickly.
I have seen many, many
poorly-informed people
on the internet
spreading their ideas.
And it's not always intentional.
There's a lot of
misunderstanding.
But you don't want to take
somebody's misunderstanding
and use it as the
guide for your life.
And that means that you
need to seek out expertise.
And we live in a time right
now where expertise is perhaps
a little undervalued, and
I think that's unfortunate.
I think that when people spend
all of their time and effort
learning about
something, they probably
have something useful
to say about it.
And we should seek out
those people when we're
trying to make our decisions.
Anybody can have an opinion,
but not everybody's opinion
is equally valid.
The other thing
that I would say is
to read laterally, which
is a new term to me,
so I'll just define it.
You might already be
completely familiar with it.
So the idea is that,
especially on the internet,
if you're reading vertically,
you're starting at the top,
and you're reading
down to the bottom.
And that doesn't always
give you as much information
about that source
as you would like.
So to read laterally,
what you do
is, you actually open
a new tab, and then
you search for the source
that you're looking at
and see what other people
have to say about it.
Because the internet
being what it is,
there will probably
be other people
who have thought about what that
source is and whether or not
it's a reliable source.
And so whenever you're deciding
whether you should believe what
you read, you should
think about who
it is that's telling you that,
why they're telling you that,
what their credentials are
for telling you that, what
their biases are behind that.
We usually recommend that people
start with government agencies.
And people don't like to hear,
start with the government
agency.
But let me just say this--
the government funds
science out of public funds,
which means that the
requirements for transparency
are very high.
Grants are reviewed
by other scientists.
Papers are reviewed
Government labs that do
research have to post their data
and make their
methods available.
That is not the case
for private think tanks,
and it may not be clear where
their money is coming from,
why they're giving
you that information.
So think what you may
about government agencies,
but it's at least a very
good place to start.
So I always like the National
Institutes of Health.
There are multiple
institutes of health.
They often produce
fact sheets, which
are very helpful, the
Centers for Disease Control.
The World Health
Organization, while not
being truly a
governmental agency,
is also a very reliable
source, and the FDA, as well.
Seek out expertise,
and then look
for consensus in the field.
So I say this because I actually
teach at a medical school,
and I have my students review
scientific papers for me.
And I always have a student
that reviews a paper
about the dangers of vaccines.
And here's my point about that.
Vaccines aren't covered
in the book, first of all.
So my point about
that is, yes, you
can always find some
scientific literature that
will review the risks.
And it's not that
there aren't any risks,
and it's not that those things
aren't worth investigating,
but you need to look at the
entire body of literature
surrounding any topic
before you make a decision.
There are lots of different
opinions in science,
and that's good.
There should be lots
of different opinions.
But when you're
trying to figure out
the global truth about a
topic, what everybody thinks
is going to settle
closer to the truth
than what any individual thinks.
So it's important to think
about what everybody is saying,
not just what one paper says.
One paper is never enough to
make a decision about anything.
And then finally-- or
not finally, I have more.
Next, I would say understand
probabilities, at least
a little bit.
Because scientists like
to speak in probabilities,
which can be very
frustrating for people.
They want to know, will
this give me cancer or not?
But that's not how life works.
Because everything
is multifactorial.
So everything has a probability
or a chance of impacting
anything happening to you.
And a scientist will very
rarely say, if you eat this,
you will die of cancer.
They will say,
this will increase
your risk of dying of cancer.
So think about what
that means really,
how it applies to you, how it
applies to your particular risk
category.
Because not everything
is going to apply
to everybody in the same way.
I would say, be skeptical.
And this is a skill that we
maybe have lost a little bit.
It's important for
somebody to convince you
of why what they're
saying is true.
First, when you hear something,
when somebody says to you,
you should definitely
panic about this right now,
your first instinct
should be, why?
Why should I panic
about that right now?
And if you give me
a good reason, then
maybe I will panic about it.
And then actually,
my last point is,
I would say don't
panic about it.
And that's easier said
than done, even for me.
I can stand here and say,
don't panic about it.
And then I'll go home and
have a little minor freakout
about something.
But for me, and I
think for everybody,
it can help to
make an action plan
and do something
about the things
that you can do
something about and stop
worrying about the things that
you can't do anything about.
I'm not the first person
to have said that.
I'm just suggesting
that you apply
a logical and rigorous method
to thinking about the things
that you want to worry about.
Would you like to add
anything, Dr. Chudler?
ERIC CHUDLER: No.
No.
LISE A. JOHNSON: OK.
So at this point, we
have a couple of minutes.
So we can go through a
couple more examples,
or we could go to questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm wondering if
you have anything
to say about the disconnect
between what you may logically
understand is something
not to be worried
about but subconsciously
or against your logic,
you are worrying
about it anyway.
And I think for a
lot of people, it's
probably the size
of the bubble is
a indicator of how much they'll
worry about it, regardless
of where it is on that plot.
So do you have any
techniques for how
to let your logical thinking
start to overcome the worry?
LISE A. JOHNSON: Well, I can
tell you what works for me,
but I don't know that that
would work for everybody.
And Eric probably has a
comment on that, as well.
Although I don't think
he worries in general
as much as I worry about things.
So for me, this
process actually really
helps, to go through and
look at what the evidence is,
and then to make a
conscious decision.
And then remind myself
every now and then,
like I already
decided I'm not going
to worry about flame
retardants, because I can't
do anything more about it.
But that's not always
enough for everybody,
especially if you tend to
be a higher anxiety person.
And there are other
techniques, obviously,
for just dealing with stress.
Like exercise is really good at
reducing people's stress level,
or meditating, or praying,
or a lot of other techniques.
The world is a stressful
place, and like there's
no way that you're
going to eliminate
all of the things
that could potentially
kill you or hurt you.
So in some sense, you have
to come to grips with that
in whatever way you can.
So this can help to some extent,
but maybe not all the way,
is what I would say.
ERIC CHUDLER: And you
might think to yourself,
why would someone have worry
about a particular thing
if they're really logic
doesn't point that direction.
And I think part
of that reason is
because some of these
things that happen rarely--
for example, shark attacks.
Some people are afraid of
getting eaten by a shark.
How many people do you think
a year get killed by sharks?
Just throw out some numbers.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ERIC CHUDLER: 100.
Five in the entire world.
How many people do you think get
attacked, an unprovoked shark
attack in the world?
What number?
Not killed, just attacked,
bitten by a shark.
How many?
Throw out some numbers.
AUDIENCE: 50.
AUDIENCE: 10.
ERIC CHUDLER: 50, 10, yeah.
So now you're kind
of going down.
But it's less than 100
in the entire world.
And think of all the
Millions of people
that swim in the ocean.
Yet people are afraid
of shark attack.
Well, it's because when a
shark attack does happen,
it's horrific.
So every time a
surfer's surfboard
gets chopped by a
shark, it's in the news.
And so the media
plays up these things,
and plays on people's
fears, and so that
might cause some illogical
fears and worries in people.
But when you look at the real
data, a lot of these things
are nothing to worry about.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
LISE A. JOHNSON: Hi.
ERIC CHUDLER: You mentioned
that, when I do research,
I should look at the entire
body of scientific literature,
not just read one piece.
But I think historically,
a lot of things
have been breakthroughs
because they were
in the minority or unique--
for example, Darwin, Galileo.
And these people have
historically always
been persecuted.
So I guess my question is--
like nowadays, the people who
are into anti-vax probably
feel that way.
And I can't convince
them they're wrong.
And I'm wondering, how
do I interact with people
who feel this way?
LISE A. JOHNSON: I
feel like we have
multiple questions
in there, so let me
see if I can unpack
them a little bit.
So first is the point about,
science has always been,
the minority is
pushing it forward.
I think that that's actually an
exception rather than a rule.
So it's notable when it happens,
because it happens rarely,
not all the time.
So yes, it does
sometimes happen.
So you have to acknowledge
that sometimes everybody
thinks there's an
ether and there's not.
But often, science moves forward
through lots of small steps
and a group of people
pushing something forward.
So that's the first thing.
The second thing
is, you're right.
You will never convince
somebody against their will.
People don't want to be wrong.
So there's only so
much you can do.
And I think in
some ways, you have
to just be at peace with that.
Like you can't convince
everybody all the time.
But you can only do what
you can do about yourself,
and make choices for
yourself, and make
choices for your family.
And that's at least my opinion
on how to interact with people.
I still try.
I'm a huge sort of
science advocate,
an advocate for logical thinking
and for looking at data.
The day that our
book was released,
I got an angry email from
somebody about fluoride.
I can't change
that person's mind.
It doesn't matter how
much data I show them,
how much data people research.
If you don't want to
believe it, you don't.
AUDIENCE: Quick followup
if you don't mind--
you said you can't change
how other people are,
but you also said that you
advocate scientific thinking.
I imagine you want to pass
this onto your children,
your spouse.
And my question is, how do I
help my partner worry less.
And I'm asking for a friend.
[LAUGHTER]
LISE A. JOHNSON: So
your friend's partner--
it depends on your
friend's partner, really.
So I guess I would try and
stay away from being judgy.
So if you come to somebody with
an open mindset and an openness
to talk about
things, you're going
to get a lot farther than if you
come out of the gate swinging,
is what I would say.
Maybe you have some--
ERIC CHUDLER: No.
No, and I think it's a lost
skill that perhaps we may not
be able to change
adults' thinking,
but trying to culture
critical thinking skills
in children and young
students, perhaps that's
one way we can
combat some of this,
these falsehoods
that we know about.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for speaking.
I was wondering how
preventability interacts
with things that are
as a group preventable,
but as an individual you
can do very little about.
Like climate change
is an example,
that individually we
can almost do nothing,
but would be addressable if
there were a group action.
LISE A. JOHNSON: So
in the book, we really
only thought about things you
can do personally to prevent.
Obviously, corporate action is
a much more difficult problem.
I don't have any great
answers for that.
I think, like, vote is obviously
a big win, but not perfect,
and community organization
and a number of other things.
That's a tough nut.
I don't know if I have anything.
ERIC CHUDLER: Yeah, that's the
only thing that I thought of,
is voting for the
types of things
that you think people
should be doing.
Vote.
AUDIENCE: So my question
might be a little bit related.
I've noticed there are certain
cases where our worries, even
though they are on the
unlikely site, the fact
that we worry changes
it, makes it unlikely.
Let me give you an example.
Let's say turning America
into dictatorship theocracy,
anything else that
it's not today--
it's not happening,
and the priority
is low, because we worry about
it all the time, because we
can do something about it.
So it's low.
If you look at the
probability, it's low.
The impact this high, but it's
low because of our worries.
What do you think about that?
LISE A. JOHNSON: Yeah,
when I see students
that are about to defend
their dissertations,
and they're really stressed
out about it, I'm like,
I'm not worried about
you, because you're
worried about it.
And if you weren't worried about
it, then I would be worried.
And I think that's sort
of a similar situation.
But I actually think
that that means
that it is high on the
preventability scale, that it
doesn't happen because
it is preventable,
and we take action against
it, and that prevents it
from happening.
AUDIENCE: Yes, but it's
low on the probability.
LISE A. JOHNSON: Well,
it's unlikely to happen
because it's highly preventable,
I guess, is what I would say.
ERIC CHUDLER: And that's
actually interesting.
Perhaps that's a new
chapter for the book.
And that would be, should
you worry about worrying?
And the answer is probably
yes, because worrying does
have physiological effects.
It could reduce your sleep.
It can cause stress, which cause
other physiological problems.
So worrying about worrying
is probably something
that we should worry about.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LISE A. JOHNSON: Or do
something about, yeah.
AUDIENCE: You mention about
government organizations,
but we have some examples,
like Flint, crisis
where they were untruthful.
So how do you look critically
at government sources, as well?
LISE A. JOHNSON: So
I guess first of all,
I would distinguish
between different kinds
of government organizations.
So when I'm talking about
government organizations,
I'm talking about research-based
government organizations, not
necessarily city or
government officials that
are enacting policy.
I think that's
slightly different.
But again, so I think
government fact sheets
are good places to start.
And in some cases, I think
they're good places to finish,
as well.
But if it's something that
you're concerned about,
then there are other resources.
And there's other governments
with other fact sheets,
so that works, as well.
So the National Health
Service in the UK
produces their own set of fact
sheets and you can compare.
But then you can also go
to the primary literature.
I try and caution people
when they do that,
because the chances
of misinterpretation
if you're not part of that
field can be pretty high.
But that's always an
option that's out there.
There are online databases.
So Google Scholar is the
one that I always use.
But there's also PubMed,
and you can look there
for primary information
and seek out those sources
and read them for yourself.
AUDIENCE: How do you guys
factor in return on investment
for preventability?
Say something's
very preventable,
but I'd have to sell my
home and move to Alaska.
LISE A. JOHNSON:
That's why it's like
a three-dimensional problem.
So it's very preventable,
but it's very unlikely.
Probably don't sell your
house and move to Alaska.
You're increasing your odds of
getting eaten by a polar bear,
so you have to really
factor that in as you're
making that decision.
And also the size of the
risk, and just prioritizing,
is it really that
important to me
that it's worth making a
major lifestyle change?
And I think that's kind of
what it comes down to is,
get all of the
data, and then say,
well, what's it worth to me?
And is it worth the cost?
Is it really just a very
small marginal return,
or is it going to
make a huge difference
in my quality of life?
And nobody can make
that decision for you.
You've got to do your own thing.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank
you very much for coming
to talk to us today.
[APPLAUSE]